[音楽]
私は大学1年生の時にまんま
という団体を立ち上げましたそれから3年家族留学という取り組みを中心に展開をして
います
家族留学うっていうと家族で何か
外国を学びに留学に行くんですかとか思われる方もいると思うんですけど
これは海外に留学に行くんじゃなくて
国内の子育て家庭に若者が留学に行く
そんな事業です
これ右側が受け入れてくださった後かて左側がカップルで家族留学に参加した学生さん
です
こんな風に子育て家庭に1日密着して留学に行く
それを通して自分自身の生き方を考え直すそんなキャリアプログラムです
実はですねーこれ左側のお二人カップルなんです
自分たちの将来を一緒に考えたいそんな思いで家族留学に一緒に参加してくれました
最初カップル留学したいです言われたとき
これは止めた方がいいのかなってしょうと思いました
は互いの人生観をすごく率直に話すのでもし会ってなかったら家族留学が原因で別れ
ました
とか言われたらどうしようかなって思ったんですけどでもこの2人も参加してお互いの
人生なかなか自分たちの将来の事って改めて話すことないんですよね
お互いの将来の話をして今まで参加したカップルたちはすごく仲良くなってくれました
あの別れないでどうか続いてほしいなあといつも願いながら軽く留学をやっています
家族留学は何をするかというとすごくシンプルです
特別なことをするわけでありませんこうやって子供たちと一緒に遊んだり一緒にお
昼ご飯を作ったりします
そしてその場でわからないことはどんどん聞いていきます
子どもが泣いたときどうするんですかとかこれご夫婦でお二人で手前の学生さんが話
聞いてるんですけど
例えばを広くはいつもどっち作っ作ってるんですかとかどうしてこの人と結婚したん
ですかとか
子供も破れて変わったことてなんですかとか
なかなか聞けないですよね受講へ20校への人たちにそんなプライベートなことって
なかなか聞けない
でもその人の家の中に入ったからこそその人たちの本当の姿を知って本当の話を聞く
ことができます
その中で得られたたくさんのヒントをもとに自分の人生を改めて考え直して未来に
前向きになってもらいたい
それが家族留学の企画です
なかなか就職活動のタイミングに働くってことを考えるんですけどちょっとその時に
将来の結婚子育てっていう働くの先も意識し始める人が大学生世代にたくさん出てきて
います
そんなときに実際に子育て家庭に入って話を聞く
その経験を通して自分自身のキャリアを考えて平井に前向きを夏になってもらいたい
それが家族留学のプログラムです
今ではこんな風に自分のプロジェクト家族留学についてみなさんの前でお話をする
くらい
ちょっという今日も出ています
でも実は大学1年生の夏
私は普通じゃないっていう風な診断をされました
パーソナリティー障害そして adhd というふうに病院で言われたことがあります
パーソナリティ障害っていうとなかなか聞き慣れない言葉かなと思います
パーソナリティー障害っていうのはその人の持っている性格が今の時代の社会的ルール
とか
気配に合わないそんな状態を指しています
例えばずーっと昔だとお殿様がいて
たくさんお嫁さんをとっていた時代があったかもしれません
でも今の時代にそれをやると
ちょっとおかしい人がなってなっちゃいますよね
そんな風に時代によって社会のルールは違います
そしてそのルールに合う部分合わない部分があって
合う人合わない人がいます
そのように社会のルールに合わないそれをまとめて
パーソナリティー障害って呼んだりします
私自身は自分がすごい悲しいなぁって思ったときにその気持ちをうまく整理できなくて
起こしちゃったりとか気持ちを整理するって言うことにあんまり得意じゃなかった損な
性格を持っていました
それが自分自身も周りもクリ責めてしまうことがあった
だからパーソナリティー障害っていうような診断をされたそんなことがありました
普通になれない普通にならなきゃずっと私は葛藤していました
最初は病名なんてついてなかったんですけど
4年前のちょうど今頃ここ札幌に旅行に来ていた時に
あなたのその性格さすがにやばいから
病院行った方がいいんじゃない
そう当時一番仲の良かった友達に言われました
ん
すごくショックだったけどその一言で踏ん切りがついて
1回病院に行ってみようそういうふうに言って病院に行ってみのところでこの診断をさ
れました
最初はすごくショックで病名がついたこともすごくショックだったし
親しい人に責められたこともすごくショックだったしとにかくまずショックでした
でもなによりもすごくほっとしました
これまでは私が普通じゃないから普通にならなきゃいけない私が普通じゃないから誰か
を傷つけている
ずっとそう思っていました
ずっと頑張ってでも変われない自分を責めていました
でも診断されたことであ
普通になれなかったんだ
頑張ってどうにかなる問題じゃなかったんだ
そう思ったらすごく肩の荷が下りた気がしました
そもそも私が多い求めてた普通ってなんだったんだろう
そう考えるようになりました
嫌なことをされてもへドーリーなきゃいけない悲しいって思ってもくらいなきゃいけ
ない
世の中には私以外にもいろんな普通思っている人がいると思うんです
可愛くなきゃ賢くなきゃコミュニケーション法買って友達がいっぱいなきゃいけない
でもそんな普通って実は誰かが決めたもので実体がないんじゃないか
そう思うようになりました
それから少しずつ私は普通にならなきゃっていう気持ちから解き放たれていく
そんな感じがしました
私はこの親鸞を受けたことそして高校時代に
npo カタリバという npo に出会ったことをきっかけに少しずつ普通じゃなく
ていい
そう思えるようになってきた気がします
npo カタリバというのは高校生向けに
けりゃ教育プログラムをやっている npo です
私はここでたくさんの大学生
そして社会人の先輩たちに出会いました
私は台がこういう年間に卒業して大きな会社に入る
それが普通だと思っていました
でも語りまで出会った先輩たちは
体調を崩して大学を6年くらい通っている人もいたし
最初に入った内服が合わなくて辞めちゃった人もいました
私がこれまで知っていた普通とはちょっと違う人たちでした
でも
だからといってその人たちが何かを通っていることはなくて
普通じゃない人たちこそすごくキレイですごく楽しそうですごく魅力的に見えました
今まで必死に追いかけていた普通を別に追いかけなくてもいいんじゃないか
総合ようになったし自分自身の人生を自分自身で決めていく
そんなヒントをたくさんもらった気がします
でも語り場で出会った人たちはキャリアのことお仕事のことを勉強のことをばっかりを
教えてくれましました
でも私には昔からもう一つ気になる事がありました
将来あったかい家族を作りたいなずっとそう思ってたんです
でもさっきみたいな親鸞をされて
しかし人との関係スラー私はうまく作れませんでした
そんな私には温かい家族を作るなんて一生かけてもかなわないかもしれない
そう思っていました
でも語り場でたくさんの人に会って自分の生き方のヒントをもらって普通じゃなくて
いい
いろんな考え方を知ることができました
だったら
それと同じでたくさんの家族に会ってたくさんの家族からヒントをもらったら自分自身
のその夢をかなえる何かきっかけになるんじゃないか
いろんな家族に会ってみたい
そういう風に思うようになりました
でも当時の私は人前で話のも全然好きじゃなくて
委員長とか部長とかそういうなリーダーシップを取るような経験とか新しいことする
ような経験をしたことがありませんでした
そんな私にとってはいろんな家族にアポイントをとって会いに行って話を聞く
それはすっごくハードルの高いものに思われました
でもこのまま
自分の夢が一生かなわないかもしれないそんな気持ちを抱えて
頑張っても頑張っても近い時の関係をうまく築けない
どう頑張っても変われないその実房の中にいるよりは新しいことに挑戦して死ぬほど
失敗して
死ぬほど悔しい思いをするそっちの方がまだよっぽどマシなんじゃないか
そういうふうに思になってきました
この今の辛いん辛い辛すぎる今を変えられるかもしれない
そんな思いでまんまという団体を立ち上げることにしました
何もやったことがなかった私は
とにかくいろんな家族を見たいいろんなママたちから話を聞きたいそんな思いで
たくさんのプロジェクトにチャレンジをしました
働いているお母さんたちに声をかけてインタビューをしました
そして託児所にインターンに行かせてもらって家族っていうものを支えるそんな場所を
見に行きました
いろんなことを1年間トライしてみてその結果たどり着いたのが
家族留学でした
実際にその人たちの暮らしを体験してその人たちのリアルな声をその場で聞くことが
できる
その面白くファーが投資をして今は全国22の都道府県に広がっています
私もこの家族留学を通して本当にたくさんのことを学びました
お父さんお母さんたちもすごく自分たちの生き方を模索していること
子育ては自分ひとりでせるものじゃなくて家族や周りを巻き込んでチームでやること
沢山の子育てのをしているご家庭からたくさんのヒントをもらいました
その子とは
私の考え方や人との接し方を大きく書いていきました
そして何より
生き方と同じで家族のあり方にも普通なんてなくて
自分らしく自分たちらし買っていい
そんなことを教えてもらいました
私は一度普通じゃないそんな診断をもらいました
でもそのあといろんな病院を回って
いろんな意見を求めに行きました
そしたら最初はパーソナリティー障害って言われたけど
その後 adhd って言われてその後
まあ広い意味で軽度の発達障害があるかもしれないですね
まあ気にするほどの事じゃありませんよそういう先生もいました
つまり私が何者か私が普通か否か
それはお医者さんにも誰にも決められないんじゃないか
どんどんそういう風に思うようになっていったんです
ずっと普通になりたい普通を求めていました
でもお医者さんだって普通はわからないし
人に会えば会うほど普通なんてどこにもない
そういう風に思うようになっていきました
普通じゃない自分を許せるように普通じゃなくて当たり前なんじゃないか
そう思うようになっていきました
そうしたら少しずつ気持ちが楽になっていって
自分のできないこと自分の苦手なことを認められるようになりました
例えば私ひとりじゃあちょっとままは大丈夫とか私の未来はきっと楽しい
そんな風に希望を持って生き続けることは難しいときがあります
でもそんな時ひなちゃんならきっと大丈夫そう思ってくれる人がいたらその私の足り
ない部分は少しずつ
保管されて私は少し前向きになることができます
ママーというチームは今10人くらいになります
でも私はみんなの気持ちを風にわかってあげることはできません
そんな時にみんなと話すことが得意でみんなの気持ちを考えることが得意な仲間が
サポートしてくれます
前は普通になりたくて
もっとみんなの気持ち分かるようにならなきゃ
感じ取れない私が悪いんだ
もっと前向きにならなきゃなんでこんなにチャレンジできないんだろう
普通になれない自分のところを数えてはすごく自分自身を責めていました
でもできないんだって思うようになったら自分で線を許せるようになったし
その事を知ってたくさんの人が助けてくれるようになりました
こうしてままは全国に広がりいろんな企業とコラボレーションしたり大学と
コラボレーションしたり自分じゃ思ってもみなかったところに展開をしていきました
そして受け入れ家庭の人たちに教えてもらった
もっとも大事なことがあります
家族はチームな
そう教えてもらいました
たった1回の数十年の人生
この人生を共に歩んでいくためのチームとして私たちは家族を持っている
私たちはみんなどこかできるところできないところがいっぱいあって
できないところがあるからこそ自然と結びついてチームを作っていく
普通じゃないからこそ人は結びつき合うんじゃないか
普通じゃないってすごく素敵なことだなそう思うようになりました
誰かが決めた普通とか自分が勝手に思い込んでる普通追い求めるんじゃなくて
ただ自分ひとりとして出来ること出来ないことそれを受け止めること
そしてできないからこそ助けてもらって助けてあげて
お互いにつながりあっていく
そんな家族や団体や
そんな支えるチームがこれからももっともっと増えていったら私たちの未来はもっと
明るく素敵なものになっていくんじゃないかそう思っています
今日はお時間頂きありがとうございました
[拍手]